you've had these different surgeries to
make you look more Korean and then when
do you go you know what
I'm not sure I should have done this
when does how does that happen well
actually it kind of developed because
I've got to a point I had more surgery
last year I had um so many surgeries I
think I went under knife three times
last year
um I had the eye surgery and that's when
I said you know I feel Korean why not if
everyone else can identify in different
ways
um and then earlier this year I actually
underwent 11 surgeries in one day and
you know I'm very happy with the results
now it made my face at the time more
feminine and you know I was unhappy
still and I thought maybe I'm trapped in
the wrong body and it sounds crazy but
you know I became trans for a while
because my whole life you know I was
always a bit more feminine I didn't fit
in and I generally thought you know if
Society is saying oh it's normal to
transition and stuff I kind of fell for
that and I was like okay maybe I'm meant
to be a woman sorry you say Society is
saying it's normal to transition
how how did you get that impression
because we all live in our own bubbles
now don't we like the the bubble that I
live in I don't think that is the common
the common thread you know what I mean
so so when you say society says it's
normal to transition what do you mean so
basically if you go online on any social
media platform or indeed in the school
system in America
um kids are being taught from a young
age they're transitioning you know do
you can do it as a kid
um obviously I'm an adult so I
transitioned as an adult but you know
when you've got everyone around the
world Educators people on social media
celebrities you know normalizing this
and saying it's easy as one two three no
I thought it was an easy thing and I had
the facial feminization I was actually
going to go do body surgery as well
thankfully I didn't you know but when
you have that constantly pushed
particularly online I spent all my time
online because almost on social media
and stuff and you know it's so easy it's
so normal you know maybe so that's what
you're being told you're being told
having surgery is easy it's normal it's
and also transitioning you know if
you're if you're feeling lost if you're
feeling confused with your gender it's
because you are trans is because you're
trapped in the wrong body so I thought
that I was trapped in the wrong body so
I thought you know maybe the Korean
thing is not not right it's maybe it's
actually the fact I'm in the wrong
gender so I transitioned I had facial
feminization I had I mean my forehead
bones that shaved down my eyebrow bone
shaved down had another eye surgery chin
uh cheek fat removed here like did so
many things and you know I love the
results now because it looks nicer than
I was but um at the same time I just
feel like
um I could have done more to myself I
was going to go to Thailand and do body
surgery I could have died and I would
have also been left with deep regret for
the rest of my life so no I just think
my message is you know not to stop
people doing these things people want to
do it if that's what they really believe
do it but just just you know educate
yourself on the risks and also don't
rush into things you know don't do
something because it's trending all
because people on social media are
saying do this it's easy you know for
kids in America when they're being told
um by influencers or schools that you
know at age 12 take puberty blockers we
can give you a double mastectomy when
it's it's comes across as it's easy and
they don't realize you know there's a
lifelong consequence these kids will be
on medication for their whole life
there's a lot of Health implications
there's not enough research so that's
the reason you know I'm trying to share
to try and help people I'm an adult but
people so people are being children are
being misinformed uh so come back to the
story because I interrupted you I just
felt that that was an important point of
pleasure yeah yeah but you you have all
these surgeries and you thought you were
trans for a while after thinking you're
and when do you go actually you know
what maybe I'm I'm neither maybe I'm
just well it was again it was about four
months ago so I got to a point where I
was still unhappy I was thinking okay I
became Korean I became trans I've had
all this surgery now I'm thinking about
doing more surgery irreversible surgery
that I really can't change is this what
I want you know I look in the mirror
every day and I'd have the surgery and
for two months I would be so happy it's
weird because when I have a swollen face
I actually feel beautiful sounds weird
but that was when I feel my most
beautiful and then after that wears off
I kind of feel like oh I look too normal
um so it got to a stage where I'm
thinking okay am I crazy say like have I
got body dysmorphia why am I doing this
you know I was losing relationships with
friends family you know everyone was
moving away from me because they were so
upset with what I was doing and
obviously people online
um were upset with me and stuff and I'm
thinking what am I doing to myself so
um I actually was lost and I was
thinking I need direction in my life so
I thought let me just go to church I
hadn't been to church in years I used to
go as a kid I was actually a raised
atheist but I used to go as a kid at a
church of England school and I just went
into church just like let me just have
some peace let me sit calmly at the back
and think and reflect on my life and
that was a defining moment for me it was
like
um you know stop what you're doing just
be happy with who you are and then I
started going to church more started
reading the Bible just the teachings
um of Jesus and I realized you know it's
like just be you know be the way you
were born you know stop doing all this
crazy thing because at the end of the
day it's not fulfilling me it's not
giving me happiness it's harming me it's
harming other people you know what's the
point of all this it doesn't even matter
what I look like it's what's inside that
counts and that's when I also had an
Awakening as like you know I actually
regretted what I was doing online on
Tick Tock and stuff because maybe I was
persuading people to have surgeries or
maybe I was persuading people to become
Korean or whatever and I felt you know
actually I have a moral responsibility
with you know I've got two million
followers online I have a responsibility
for these kids these people that look up
to me I need to send them a good message
you know so that's why I've kind of been
trying to do some activism to try and
spread love and positivity in the world
and just to try and you know spread a
better message rather than you know
getting surgery is cool being Korean is
cool you know it's I just felt bad for
what I was doing